Hey, welcome back. So, we have a 2007
Nissan Sentra. We have one remote does
not work. Uh buttons broken. Basic key
and it's like held on with glue. It's
going to fall apart any time. We're
going to make a new key and fob. Let's
go ahead and get started. So, we have
our plugged in smart pro.
Let's go ahead and do the remote first.
Follow the SOP. I'm going to switch to
the on mode. We're going to look. We
have a mobilizer and remotes. Let's
click on that.
Voltage is pretty good for this old car.
Oh, I scared it. Cool. Switch on.
Hazards
on.
And let's do remotes.
Switch it on. Yes. Press lock button.
No. Complete.
And let's take this out. And check.
Nice.
Cool.
Trunk opened. I heard it. Cool. Let's go
ahead and we're going to go to program
keys.
I'm going to press the lock button.
Insert key one. And so we have key one
and key two.
Yes. Switch on.
Let's try the old pin code. Just being
systematic.
And we switch off.
We're going to switch it on. It should
flash five times.
Oh, yep. It's flashing. Good.
Yes. Let's program more keys and we
switch off.
Okay. Insert the next key. So, I'm going
to take this one down. Grab the new one.
In and on. Mobilizer lights flashing
five times. Good. Okay. No more keys. We
switch off.
Cycle keys twice. So, one, two,
take it out. Put in key one.
Switch on. Mobilizer lights off. and
engine starts and we're good to go.
Let's turn off the hazards.
So, that key starts. Let's check the new
key
and we're good to go. Cool. Under two
minutes or under three minutes. Other
than that,
great key and remote combo for this
happy customer. Other than that, have a
great day and I'll see you next time.
See you. Bye.